alright coming up next it's a UFC
lightweight division bounty
[Music]
you ready you ready well it's one of the
loudest venues in all the mixed martial
arts as we get underway here at the Bell
Centre in Montreal
zowie one is UFC debut by knockout so
you gotta think the confidence
[Applause]
backhaul he might be out
tagsam well he left his head open there
Joe and he got cracked with
[Applause]
beautiful kayo for the victory early in
the first yes sir it goes into the books
as a first round win by knockout near
perfect execution the technique was
absolutely gorgeous and again when you
catch a guy early maybe getting him coal
before he's had a chance to work up a
sweat or even get into the flight a
little bit those strikes can have a
bigger effect and it certainly did here
tonight and there he is after the huge
knockout turned in tonight near perfect
execution and one of the bigger
highlights of his UFC career here is
Bruce Bucky
ladies and gentlemen definitely on his
pulse top for this contest I'd 1 minute
1 second of the very first round
declaring the winner so just the way he
threw it up here tonight what a
monumental moment and knockout to get
his hand raised here tonight he kept the
judges out of it he has certainly set
himself up for a major opportunity here
moving forward but you can be sure
tonight is about this knockout he'll be
celebrating deep into the night
right
[Music]
let me working and right coming right
[Music]
that's how you block
nice block
[Applause]
[Music]
the mother's room
you ready Dateline Las Vegas Nevada
we're underway here at the MGM Grand
Garden Arena well it's good to see this
man back inside the Octagon round 1
getting underway Horace Mann
no his last plate by blistering knocked
out his popularity has absolutely soared
since so with momentum tonight they'll
try to keep the winning street and the
knock
[Applause]
back up hard huh
well not a good look there Joe as he
eats a shot to the body it looks like
he's becoming increasingly more
vulnerable to that his right certainly
have the body wide open on that tag zone
they're working from the clinch once
more double underhooks now Joe
[Applause]
that he might have landed there he moves
to the muy Thai clinch three minutes to
go he's got a single leg takedown back
up Oh beautiful beautiful kick to the
body pretty good straight punch for him
there show fainting ho nice inside leg
kick right there Oh
he's doing a really good job of timing
these shots he's keeping his head
protected here excellent blocking
tagging and he lands a nice goal both
been exchanged
[Applause]
back to the feet now oh nice
90 seconds to go in the opening round Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so here we go with round one
this young contender has won his last
three fights and as many of you know
each knockout more impressive than the
last will try to extend the knockout
streak here tonight to continue
he's just full mouth Marshall first
round is underway you know when it comes
to his strategy a lot of that is rooted
in his kicking game has massive power
whether he's attacking the head the legs
or the body so let's see how early he
can find his range with those kicks here
tonight back to the feet now
all lands a nice straight changes his
stance in exchanges all aims that punch
so there's his person it kicking that
land so no surprise really Joe that he
goes to that weapon early and is able to
realize some success here in the south
these guys we're here oh look at this
hurt him with that uppercut
[Applause]
Cham how about that chin
he is really finding a home for those
body kicks beautiful uppercut
that one hurt caught that one on the
forearm
[Applause]
he's in a lot of trouble
huge right hand shot that got him the
victory
yeah Joe beautiful shot to end the fight
right there it couldn't have landed much
more